Now that‘s Eatin‘ Good
in the Neighborhood.
>> [CHANTING]
>> I AGREE WITH YOU, I’M WORKING
ON THEM, MAN, GIVE ME ANOTHER
FIVE DAYS.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, SO, IT’S
ANOTHER THREE DAYS FROM NOW
WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS ON THAT,
BUT AGAIN, ONE OF THOSE RARE
EVENTS, WHERE THE PRESIDENT WAS
CORNERED BY PROTESTERS ON WHAT’S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER CRISIS,
THAT HE HAS NOT DEFINED AS A
CRISIS BUT HE PROMISES TO
ADDRESS WITHIN A MATTER OF DAYS
WITH ESHALL SEE , RON PAT EL
JOINS US THE RETIRED ACTING
I.C.E. DIRECTOR, RON WHAT DID
YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL IT’S JUST A SITUATION
THAT WE’RE IN PUBLICLY, THERE’S
THIS CRISIS ON THE BORDER, AND
YOU HAVE A CERTAIN SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION, THOSE PROTESTERS
THAT WANT TO REMOVE THE
RESOURCES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY NEEDS TO HELP SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM, AND SO YOU’RE
SHUTTING DOWN THE TENSION IS NOT
GOING TO MAKE THE PROBLEMS AT
THE BORDER BETTER, IT’S NOT
GOING TO PROTECT THE HOMELAND.
THOSE ARE NECESSARY RESOURCES
AND THAT’S WHY THEY ARE IN
INVENTORY, AND TO SUGGEST THAT
WE COULD DO WITHOUT THEM, OR
THAT WE’RE GOING TO END THEM,
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME AT ALL.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, WE’RE LEARNING A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE CUT
AND FUNDING FOR THE BORDER WALL,
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAD INCLUDED IN ITS SKINNY
BUDGET.
IN OTHER WORDS, NOT INCLUDED IN
THAT SKINNY BUDGET, BUT THAT HE
HAD SPECIFICALLY CANCELED ALL
BORDER WALL PROJECTS THAT WERE
PAID FOR WITH DIVERTED MILITARY
FUNDS, SO THAT WAS A RATIONALE
FOR DOING SO, WHAT DID YOU MAKE
OF THAT?
>> WELL THAT’S LESS RESOURCES,
THAT’S LESS CAPABILITY ON THE
BORDER.
I WOULD URGE THIS ADMINISTRATION
TO HELP THE MEN AND WOMEN OF CBP
, SPECIFICALLY THE BORDER
PATROL AS IT RELATES TO THE WALL
THERE ARE KNOWN GAPS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT
EXIST RIGHT NOW AND I WOULD URGE
THEM TO CLOSE THOSE GAPS, WHEN I
WAS A CHIEF IN RIO GRANDE VALLEY
WE HAD PUT UP THE WALL AND WE
INTENDED TO PUT GATES IN CERTAIN
AREAS AND THE FUNDING AND THE
RESOURCES AND THE LAWSUITS
PREVENTED US FROM CLOSING THOSE
GAPS AND THAT’S MANPOWER-
INTENSIVE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY
GUARDING THOSE GAPS 24/7 BECAUSE
THAT’S A NATURAL ENTRY POINT FOR
FOLK, AND SO I WOULD URGE
THEM TO SURE UP THE GAPS WHERE
THE 18-FOOT BARRIER HAS, THE 18-
FOOT BARRIER ON THE RIGHT
AND THE LEFT YOU GOT TO CLOSE UP
THAT GAP, OTHERWISE, YOU’RE
GOING TO BE WASTING VALUABLE
AGENT TIME TO JUST SIT AND WATCH
THAT OPENING IN THE WALL.
NEIL: RON, HOW IMPORTANT IS IT,
TO YOU, AS SOMEONE WHO WAS A
FORMER BORDER PATROL CHIEF, TO
SEE THE PRESIDENT OR  THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THAT MATTER, AT
THE BORDER, TO GO AND VISIT
THESE FACILITIES?
>> WELL, IT LEAVES A GREAT DEAL
TO THE WORKFORCE EVEN AT MY
LEVEL WHEN WE WENT OUT AUNT
VISITED THE MEN AND WOMEN ON THE
FRONTLINES AND ASKED THEM
WHAT THEIR NEEDS WERE, ASKED
THEM WHAT THEIR CHALLENGES WERE
AND THEN I COULD TAKE THAT BACK
TO WASHINGTON AND WORK WITH MY
STAFF TO TRY TO MEET THOSE NEEDS
AND THEN THERE IS THIS WHOLE
MORALE BOOST THAT COMES WITH IT.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY IN AUTHORITY,
IN THE GOVERNMENT, THAT’S IN
YOUR CHAIN OF COMMAND INCLUDING
THE PRESIDENT, THAT KNOWS WHAT
YOU DO, AND IS EAGER TO
UNDERSTAND IT, AND THEN PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND GET HIS STAFF TO
PLAN, TO SURE UP THESE GAPS, TO
HELP, YOU KNOW, AMELIORATE THIS
CRISIS I THINK IT BE VERY
VALUABLE FOR THEM TO DO.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, IT’S NOT MUCH WE
KNOW ABOUT THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PART OF THIS , OUTSIDE OF THIS
DEVELOPMENT THIS PAST WEEK
WHERE 90 PEOPLE WERE FOUND IN A
HOUSTON HOME THAT LOOKED LIKE
ANY HOME IN ANY NEIGHBORHOOD IN
THIS COUNTRY, 90 PEOPLE CROWDED
IN THERE.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT AND
THE FACT THAT MAYBE WHAT’S BEEN
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER IS WHAT
TRIGGERED IT.
>> WELL THAT’S A SYMPTOM.
THIS IS A SYMPTOM OF WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE BORDER IS IN
CHAOS.
THESE 90 PEOPLE WERE SMUGGLED
INTO THE HOUSTON AREA.
IMAGINE IF YOU LIVED ON THAT
STREET.
IMAGINE YOUR KIDS RIDING THEIR
BIKES BACK AND FORTH ALONG THAT
BLOCK HOW DANGEROUS THAT IS FOR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEN
THERE’S 90 PEOPLE IN A SMALL
FAMILY HOME, PROBABLY BEING
EXTORTED, PROBABLY BEING HUMAN
TRAFFICKED AND IF YOU’VE GOT 90
PEOPLE JUST CROSSED THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY THERE’S AT LEAST A
HANDFUL OF THEM THAT HAD
CRIMINAL RECORDS, AND SO IT’S AN
UNSAFE AND UNSANITARY
CONDITION FOR THOSE INDIVIDUAL
MIGRANTS TO BE IN, BUT IT’S ALSO
A DANGER TO THAT COMMUNITY, AND
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE DON’T HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES AND CONTROL OF THE
BORDER.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, NOW, I DO KNOW
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL TAP THE
AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE PERSONNEL TO HELP.
I DON’T KNOW SPECIFICALLY IF
IT’S GOING TO BE AT THE BORDER,
RON, WE JUST HEAR UP TO 500
INDIVIDUALS.
I’M NOT SURE IT’S GOING TO WORK
WITH THE AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT
EVER SIGNED UP FOR THAT BUT WHAT
DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> YEAH, THIS WAS DONE BEFORE
IN THE 2014 SURGE AS WELL.
YOU’RE LOOKING FOR GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY’RE CLEAR
ED AND THEY HAVE KNOWN
BACKGROUNDS SO THAT THEY COULD
INTERACT AND HELP ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THE SHELTERS OR  THE BORDER
PATROL SPACES, RIGHT?
SO THEY CAN DO THINGS THAT HELP
CARE AND COMFORT FOR THESE
MIGRANTS THAT ARE IN CUSTODY.
YOU KNOW, ROLLING BACK THIS
POLICY AND NOT HAVING
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES AT THE
BORDER IS GOING TO GO DOWN AS A
MISTAKE.
TO SAY THAT IT’S GETTING BETTER
OKAY, FINE.
THEY’VE MOVED MORE MIGRANTS OUT
OF BORDER PATROL KUDLOW LAST
MONTH AND INTO HHS CARE, BUT NOT
HAVING SUFFICIENT SHELTER SPACE
AND REVERSING THE POLICY WITHOUT
, AND KNOWING THAT THAT
WAS GOING TO BE THE RESULT, IS
JUST A BIG MISTAKE, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, IT’S THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF CBP AND THEIR FAMILIES
THAT HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
STRESS AND THEY’RE THE ONES
AT THE FRONTLINE THAT SEE THE
BULK OF THIS PROBLEM.
THEY CAN’T SAY NO TO THIS
TRAFFIC, WHEN AN UN
ACCOMPANIED MINOR COMES UP
TO AN IMMIGRATION OFFICER
WHETHER CBP OR  BORDER PATROL
AGENT, THEY HAVE TO TAKE THEM
INTO CUSTODY.
THAT’S THE LAW.
THERE’S NO OPTION THERE.
THERE’S NO SPACE AT HHS, BUT IT
JUST CONTINUES TO BACKUP, AND
THEY’VE DONE BETTER BUT IT’S